bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors qu'elles font des
revendications précises des jd jaune
aujourd'hui il ya aujourd'hui les gilets
jaunes sont dans les rues pour dire stop
à cette matière est gouvernementale
c'est à dire que voilà il ya cette loi
sécurité globale qui est toujours sur la
table toujours en discussion et on
trouve que c'est vraiment une atteinte
aux libertés individuelles
là le gouvernement à chaque fois qu'on
pense il est arrivé au bout du n'importe
quoi eh bien il arrive toujours à sortir
un lapin de son chapeau et du coup là où
nous sommes aujourd'hui là pour que pour
cette raison là pour dire stop
nous avons droit de manifester les
journalistes ainsi que les tous les
manifestants en droit de filmer ce qui
passe dans les manifestations si on le
fait c'est bien évidemment ça pour
discréditer une institution qui est
celle de la police
pas du tout on rappelle uniquement qu'il
ya eu beaucoup de causes comme geneviève
le guépard exemple s'il ya des 100 lits
ces fameux le disent les images pardon
qui ont été tournées en live par les
gilet jaune est la vérité n'aurait
jamais facile puisque le procureur de
nice avait clairement menti
voilà donc à cette cause n'a déjà que
l'on défend aujourd'hui la liberté or il
en soit salie d'arrêt aux journalistes
de continuer à filmer ce qu'il fasse
dans les manifestations que les citoyens
continuent à être informés de 6 passes
et puis là l'autre l'autre c'est moi le
l'autre au rassemblement qui a s'est
effectivement contre les leurs immenses
ces licenciements pardon et du coup de
rejoindre ce cortège là pour dire stop
aussi à cela puisque depuis le colis de
écoutez il ya des structures qui font
vraiment de manière oui dd il est jaune
opposant la loi sécurité globale des
syndicats qui appellent à dénoncer les
suppressions d'emplois cette convergence
des luttes dont on parle beaucoup
est-ce qu on y est aujourd'hui bah
écoute et qu'on y est je sais pas
sincèrement je pourrais pas vrai bon
pied qu'est ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que l'egypte jaune en retour aux
faits pour cette convergence de vue
puisque nous comprenons très bien que
l'union fait la force
si nous ne luttons pas tous ensemble qui
partira peut pas fonctionner comme
chacun de notre côté 1 qui se bat pour
une liberté l'autre qui se bat contre le
contre les licenciements un autre
conseiller
enfin voilà il faut vraiment que l'on
soit tous ensemble et voilà il est le
pratique du gilet jaune justement et
pour les jeunes ont toujours défié dans
les rues pour dénoncer les injustices
sociales et fiscales et les sentiments
c'est une injustice c'est donc vraiment
ça me semble naturel d'aller rejoindre
les syndicats pour pour dire nombreux
atouts soir depuis la création du
mouvement des idées jaune des années
plus tard quel bilan dressez-vous
aujourd'hui d'écouter le bilan il est
très simple c'est que
monsieur emmanuel macron notre cher
président de la république comme ils
disent et enfin comme il a pu dire dieu
durant sa campagne électorale il a dit
aux français
attention fallait suivez-moi la police
alors voilà don kelly
comment il ma gueule mac ou a indiqué
nous allons nous avions le nain projet
c'est hilali c'est notre projet écoutez
on s'aperçoit qu'au bout de deux ans et
demi et monsieur emmanuel macron a
souhaité son gréement ils ont leurs
projets mais c'est absolument pas le
projet des citoyens français
voilà et voilà le bilan que j'enfonce
effet je suis patient lorsque vous êtes
opposants politiques aujourd'hui en
france c'est malheureux à dire mais
c'est comme ça il ya le gouvernement
adopte une toxine qui est totalement
comment dire disproportionnée puisque
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que lorsque
vous voulez des noms c'est n'importe
quoi dans le sol et y en avait bien vous
êtes réprimandé vous êtes mutilés vous
êtes vraiment donc le bilan de ces deux
ans c'est pourtant portée qu'aujourd'hui
vous ne pourriez pas vous ne pouvez pas
être un opposant politique sous peine
d'être mutilée réprimander et diagane
merci en tout cas d'avoir répondu à une
question je rappelle que vous êtes et
gilet jaune merci à vous fin